hello and welcome to see you playing
drain you again we play them earlier in
the session I go for a different setup
now now the Queens gambit you probably
get the red team and let's see what
happens yeah this is a very solid way of
playing this opening with white maybe a
low-risk white um sometimes gets a small
advantage based on the better bishops
but he rarely gets into any sort of
trouble which is not bad yeah just play
from a safe situation and see what
happens yeah this is possible but not
all that great not quite sure about
night c7 here night before was played in
a game that I had examined for my
project this should be ok I think taking
also this is a simple solution
the key ideas that always white as joins
us to put a night on FY and possibly to
d6 and that's interesting once to take
on c5 with the night okay i will ever
way going to the six here is as well wow
we played that very quickly must be very
sure that there is no technical issues
here
Bishop a3 I mean I threatened to win
apiece then look to 896 hmm maybe yeah
this is this is just working also this
move was interesting let's do this I
don't quite see how he plays it now if
he takes Bishop cakes looks excellent
actually threatening multiple things
then and I also can't they just threaten
to take on CC well how is that going to
work out for them we'll see just
accepting a worse position with Bishop
c6
and that's not easy for black I I don't
see a move to be honest a really good
move yeah so he had to find a way to two
sec second porn 96 is also pretty good
here quite sure what's best this is the
the only issue here you have various
ways of being quite substantially better
here 96 in how to channel I go 96
hmm doesn't he have to take I mean it's
a lovely b5 and see if I were hanging so
he basically has to take on
as I'm going to win some kind of
material now most likely a pawn All
Right see what he does look FC 8d sound
should immediately ended
yeah this is a bit tougher of course the
thing is I have be four and then taking
on b7 and not sure what's best or can
just take c5 and t7 of course well if I
take this and then this happen he has to
go look to the aid okay look see one
then c6 okay let's do this it's hard to
determine what's best okay so i can take
b7 now and potentially a seven
hope the eight No so maybe just go here
and then take a sound so d7 Bishop c5
right d7 black resigns yeah that opening
is it is not as easy as it seems I mean
especially if you have no no clear
preparation we should have six kind of
signals that there is no clear
preparation here for black yeah black
can take you can play this position and
then Bishop d7 and if you are very
precise you will probably draw but it's
a super no risk kind of position and he
I'm getting getting somewhere i'm just
getting getting space that's an
interesting way of playing I was
expecting this but he has to reckon with
the night coming here and potentially
the other they're so white has more
space so it's not easy for black and now
the night came to c4 and should be seven
I was kind of surprised especially how
quickly played it maybe he has to him
okay this one and this yeah then the
dead already approaches losing
evaluations on the engine spot engine
wants to play this I was thinking of
that this could be an idea yeah this
doesn't work it seems Brooksie idea
to that we are we are talking about a
lost position at minus 2 or most by the
engine before I think I played all the
engine news it looks like a cheating
game but they are not they are not that
difficult to find you know at least I
mean I played more set that looked good
I don't even calculate all that much but
it's it's all all the number one's
choice by stockfish yeah it said this is
a somewhat poisonous opening line
especially considering that it looks
utterly harmless but as we have
witnessed it can happen that small
mistakes can be very costly ok guys
thanks for watching